JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to YouTube Developers
Live take two for today.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
And I have exciting show
for you today.
We have guests from
Pixability.
Andreas, how are you doing?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Very well.
Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And Bettina?
BETTINA HEIN: Thank
you for having us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you, Bettina, today?
Great.
In the studio we have
Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: Hello.
Hello, everyone.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Long
time no see, Jeremy.
JEREMY WALKER: I know.
You're been in Mexico?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
I was down in Mexico.
We can talk a little
bit about it later.
And then Jeff is not joining us
tonight because we had to
rewire our studio.
And in the process of rewiring,
we lost Jeff.
All right.
But hopefully we'll try
to manage without him.
So first of all, thank you
very much for coming.
I'm very excited to have
you in the studio.
I know you have a very
busy schedule.
Coming from Boston, right?
BETTINA HEIN: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: To
Silicon Valley.
How long are you staying?
BETTINA HEIN: We're actually
going back tomorrow morning.
We came in on Sunday.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great.
So we're going to try to squeeze
the maximum amount of
value out of your
short trip here.
So we wanted to talk to you
about your company.
But maybe first, Bettina,
I know you've been an
entrepreneur for quite
some time.
So I wanted to learn a little
bit more about how did you get
into that and what did you
do before Pixability?
And then we will transition
and talk a little bit more
about your current project.
BETTINA HEIN: Sure.
Well, I like to brag that I've
never had a real job.
So I started my first
tech company right
out of graduate school.
Actually, I started it in
Zurich, Switzerland--
a spin-off of the Swiss
Federal Institute of
Technology.
And it was a bunch of
engineers and I.
And we started a speech
technology
company called SVOX.
And if you have an Android phone
or use Google Translate,
you will have text to speech
software from SVOX in there.
And so the technology today is
in the hands of over half a
billion people.
And it's in the GPS systems
of most cars.
And we raised some money for
that from investors from
Angels and VCs, about
$8 million.
And we then sold it to Nuance
Communications from
Burlington, Massachusetts
for $125 million.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's
pretty amazing.
So 10x plus return, which is
I know all businesses are
looking for.
BETTINA HEIN: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Can the text
to speech software do Polish
accent, by any chance?
BETTINA HEIN: Absolutely
it can.
Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Now I need to try it.
BETTINA HEIN: It's
available in 32
languages, I think, so far.
So, yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, wow.
Great.
So now your working
on Pixability.
So what brought you into
this world of video?
BETTINA HEIN: Well, I was
a Sloan Fellow at MIT
after I'd done SVOX.
And that was actually the time
when YouTube was getting
acquired by Google.
And I was studying technological
disruption.
And what I saw was this drop of
orders of magnitude in the
input factors into video.
So the cost of cameras, the
cost of editing software,
bandwidth, all of that
was dropping majorly.
And I knew from studying
previous technological
disruptions that that was
an opportunity to
create a big business.
And I also saw that there
was a chance for
democratization, actually.
You know, TV is an oligopolistic
game, networks,
cable TV stations.
But here small content creators,
small businesses all
had an equal chance
to succeed.
And so I decided to found
Pixability on that premise.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It sounds
very exciting.
It's also interesting that
you went from voice
and audio to video.
So I'm wondering what's
coming next, ESP?
Extrasensory--
[LAUGHTER]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But before
we get there, I'm also
curious-- and I am sure you get
that question a lot, so
pardon the repetition.
But as a woman running the
company do you think is it
easier, is it harder for you?
Do you have to answer this
question a lot of times?
We don't have a lot of female
guests on this show.
I think our entrepreneur guest
speakers are kind of a male
dominated group.
So can you speak a little bit
about your experience to all
the women that might be
watching us right now?
BETTINA HEIN: Yeah.
Well, it's almost like if I
would ask Jeremy here, I see
you're wearing glasses, what
is it like as a myopic
entrepreneur?
No, in all honesty, I get asked
that question a lot.
And I wish that weren't a
pertinent question, but it is.
It goes both ways.
It's actually a big advantage
in some ways.
If a magazine wants to cover
a hot new start up and they
have, all things being equal,
a male entrepreneur and a
female entrepreneur,
guess what?
I get chosen.
So that's the cool
thing about it.
The downside is that I have to
relate to people that have a
different interest set than I
often times, or a different
background.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I get that
a lot with football.
BETTINA HEIN: Yeah, especially
with investors, I just don't
fit the mold exactly.
So it's maybe not
as comfortable.
And a lot about business and
investing is about pattern
recognition.
And I don't fit that pattern.
But I roll with the punches.
And I like to just take
that as a challenge.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And so now I think this is a
great prelude to Pixability.
So tell us a little bit more
about the problem you're
trying to solve and how
you're approaching it.
BETTINA HEIN: Sure.
So Pixability helps companies
and content creators make the
most of their YouTube channel.
Find their audience, optimize
their content, optimize ads,
and do that all the
YouTube platform.
If you've heard of a company
that's called Buddy Media,
they do everything
for Facebook.
We do everything for YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So the target audience is
content creators that really
want to amplify their presence
on YouTube, get more
subscribers, get more views?
Or who is the customer?
BETTINA HEIN: Actually,
it's content creators.
So publishers of content as well
as corporate marketers.
Because that is actually
coming together.
We see that more and more.
If you look at Red Bull
Stratos, right?
Companies are becoming
content creators.
And content creators
are businesses.
So we serve both of those.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So maybe before we get
into more details
can we see a demo?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Sure.
Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Let's try that.
ANDREAS GOELDI: Right.
So first of all, our product
really has two
main parts to it.
So there's one part that is
really optimized to help
businesses, content creators
manage their YouTube channel.
And there's the second part that
is really optimized to
what we call to do audience
insights.
And that means basically that we
help businesses and content
creators understand what
is going on YouTube.
So basically, to answer the
question, what kind of content
should I produce?
Who are my competitors?
What is a really popular type
of video in my field?
And so on.
And that's really kind of the
combination that seems to work
extremely well.
So what we see here, to start a
quick demo, is basically the
dashboard for people who manage
their YouTube channel.
So we created a UI that is
really designed to be optimal
for business users.
And they have slightly different
needs from what you
have as a person, as an
individual, using YouTube.
Or even as a content provider.
A lot of marketing oriented
users, for instance, don't
full time manage their
YouTube channel.
It's just one part
of their job.
So they need a lot
of efficiency.
Very often you find teams
who manage two
channels at the same time.
So one person might only
upload videos.
Another person might do
all the SEO work.
And a third person approves
everything and publishes it.
So this is really designed
as a kind of multi-user
environment.
When you log in the first thing
you see is dashboard.
And this shows you some
high-level metrics like how
your viewers are currently
developing, what your traffic
sources are, where you get
your traffic, what social
engagement numbers
are, and so on.
And you also see that's
important for business users
and content creators alike,
professionals.
You see what your competitors
are up to.
So we have this online
video grader score.
It's basically a score between
0 and 100 points
that you can get.
It really measures how
successful your YouTube
channel is performing, how many
viewers you get, how many
social sharing activities you're
triggering, how you are
using videos on your
website, and so on.
And so you can configure what
your competitors are and keep
an eye on them.
You get alerts when they
publish successful
videos and so on.
So it's really an easy way
to get on top of things.
Then when you dig a little bit
more in depth-- so I'm logged
in here as one of our customers,
dailygrommet.com,
which is an e-commerce website
that introduces a new
interesting product every day.
They produce one
video per day.
So a lot of high volume
production there.
And they manage their channel
through our software.
And here you basically see the
list of videos that you have.
So that's very similar
to the video
manager in YouTube itself.
But the difference is you
have some workflow
functionality here.
So for instance, this progress
bar shows you at all times how
far advanced you are in treating
this video optimally
for business purposes for
reaching out to people.
So I click on here on one
example video I see that I'm
currently done with uploading
my video, but I still have
some work to do with SEO.
So it gives me a warning here
saying that I need to work on
my description text,
for instance.
So we baked in a lot of best
practices from our experience,
from our customer's experience,
about what makes a
video on YouTube really
successful for SEO purposes
and for discovery just to
get found by people.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
that was going
to be my next question.
So all these scores are actually
actionable, right?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: The marketer
or content creator strives to
achieve 100%.
ANDREAS GOELDI: Yup.
Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But you give
them suggestions about things
that they should do to really
improve the metrics that
you're tracking.
ANDREAS GOELDI: That's
exactly right.
So as you type here in the
description field, for
instance, actually the
score goes up.
So up to 100%.
So you always know where
you stand and what
you have to do next.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So let
me get that straight.
So typing in some
random gibberish
increases my score to 100%?
ANDREAS GOELDI: No, no.
That's was just a
minor change.
No, it actually looks at
how many different
keywords you're using--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
ANDREAS GOELDI: --in
your space.
So it's really based on
what you need to do
to get found online.
And we also have kind
of a feedback loop.
So for instance, you can at
any time see how you are
measuring up on YouTube
search against
your text, for instance.
In this case here
is a video about
particularly compact umbrella.
And we see that we are currently
ranking at number
seven for the keyword portable
umbrella and number three for
travel umbrella.
So that's pretty good.
And you get a lot of this SEO
feedback all the time so that
you know if people are actually
able to find you for
long tail searchers.
Also part of this is, of
course, analytics.
We basically tap into YouTube
analytics and add some value
on top of that, especially
making the whole thing easier
to understand for
business users.
So we're not just giving
you the raw numbers.
But we also tell you what the
next three things are that you
should be doing.
In this case here, this channel
here increased traffic
from embedded players
by a lot.
So that's great.
But you also have to do some
work here in SEO and link
building campaigns on external
sites so people know
immediately what the next
step should be.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What's a
link building campaign?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Well, basically
we are seeing that a
lot of success for YouTube
videos really comes from links
from external sites to
your video pages, to
your channel page.
And reaching out to bloggers,
for instance, to link to your
channel directly is something
that really
helps you assess your--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
I see.
Is subscriber count something
that your
also tracking as isometric?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Absolutely.
We're looking at that as well.
The reality of that is frankly
that for more marketing
oriented users subscribers
tend to
be a bit less important.
So it's mostly important for
producers of original content.
And that's definitely an
important metric as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Great.
JEREMY WALKER: So this is
a really fascinating.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the actual
implementation you did with
the YouTube APIs?
Whatever you're comfortable
with.
And maybe even the language
you used?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure, sure.
I would say we are probably
using almost every part of the
YouTube API.
We are using definitely the
Data API, allow people to
upload videos to modify metadata
and all that stuff.
We also use the Player API.
So we have some functionality
that lets people customize the
YouTube player when
they want to embed
videos on their website.
And that's something that a lot
of people don't know that
this even exists.
And finally, we used the Insight
API to pull down
statistics information.
So it's pretty broad really.
And our system is actually
implemented in Python.
Mostly we use MySQL and Redis
for data storage.
And we're currently hosted on
Amazon EC2 in the cloud.
But from the beginning we really
decided to be totally
cloud agnostic so we can
actually move to a different
cloud at any time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
ANDREAS GOELDI: Definitely
keeping an eye on Google's
Computes Cloud and other
possible solutions.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
great to hear.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Have you
looked at the new Analytics
API that we have recently
launched?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Yeah,
absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: For those of
you who are watching, we have
recently removed the whitelist
requirement from the new
Analytics API.
So historically we had the
Insight API, which is robust.
But it requires you to unzip
the file, and then
[INAUDIBLE], and so forth.
I think the new Analytics API is
a little bit easier to use.
ANDREAS GOELDI: I think it's
much better from that
perspective.
And it also helps us a lot for
kind of the second part of our
product, which is audience
insight.
And just maybe have a
quick look on that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Let's
take a look.
ANDREAS GOELDI: So what people
typically ask us when they
contact us for first time is
what kind of content should I
really create to be successful
on YouTube?
Because it's not really clear.
I mean, obviously when you're
a marketer it's not a 30
second commercial.
That probably will not
fly on YouTube.
If you're a traditional content
creator, you probably
have to change your style
a little bit to what you
normally do.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is cat videos
normally the answer?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Cat
videos is great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is that the
[INAUDIBLE] in your code?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Cat yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cat video.
ANDREAS GOELDI: If nothing
works, use cats and babies.
It always flies.
That's great.
No, I mean that's actually
a question that a lot
of people ask us.
How do I make a viral video?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
ANDREAS GOELDI: And
the reality is
there's no proof in concept.
But you really have to
understand what your industry
is doing and what people
really like in terms of
content in your industry.
So we created this product
called The Video Radar that
taps heavily into Insight
APIs, and
Search API, and so on.
And it assembles, basically,
information from YouTube about
keywords that you
initially set to
that define your industry.
So in this case here, we just
ran this analysis for a new
customer of ours, Rokenbok,
which is actually a very
successful user of YouTube
advertising especially.
Some amazing videos.
They're a toy company.
They make educational toys
where you can build very
complex models.
And it's very sophisticated
stuff.
And they gave us a bunch of
keywords here that we use to
analyze their space
on YouTube.
And this first graph here shows
you the visualization of
what the most popular channels
in this whole
educational toy space are.
So there's a company called
Bruder Toys, which is one of
their competitors.
There's Toys "R"
Us, of course.
And there's K'NEX, another
competitor.
And a bunch of just channels run
by individuals who happen
to be very fascinated by
these educational toys.
So then from thereon you can
basically drill down into a
number of different metrics.
You can figure out how
many views in total
there are on the space.
And how many relevant videos
are out there.
You can look at what the top 100
videos are in your space,
who the most successful
content produces are.
And finally, you can actually
drill down in full detail into
each of these channels and
figure out what they are doing
well and what they are
not doing so well.
So here the number one ranked
channel, which is a competitor
of our customer, has
a lot of use.
That's great.
But they also have a relatively
moderate sentiment.
So about equal number of
likes and dislikes.
Not a tremendous amount
of Facebook
activity and Twitter activity.
So you can use this information
to figure out what
are these guys doing well, what
are success recipes that
we should copy apart from
cats and babies.
And what should we avoid because
it clearly doesn't
seem to fly?
We're also using this
information for ad targeting,
for instance.
So we actually provide our
customers with a list of
channels that they can use
to promote their videos.
And we also help them to find
the right online communities
for social engagement,
for social sharing.
So it's a very broad tool that
helps people understand the
entire space.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
JEREMY WALKER: That's great.
Just out of curiosity, did you
run into anything that was
counterintuitive using
the YouTube APIs?
Or anything that you kind
of saw some issues with?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Specifically
for the API--
so first of all, YouTube's API
is way more robust and mature
than other APIs, like
Facebook's, or Twitter's, or
especially LinkedIn, which tends
to never work at all.
So it's a very robust API.
But the surprise is that you
really have to still build a
bit of infrastructure
around it.
So a typical topic
is quota issues.
We are a very heavy
user of the API.
And occasionally we run
into coda issues.
And you have to put in a lot
of functionality to really
accommodate these issues
and work around them.
So you have to catch all these
potential errors, and so on,
and special cases.
So this needs a little bit of
infrastructure on the side of
the API user really.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Similar
question to Bettina, when you
were building the company,
building the product, anything
that really surprised you
about your audience?
Or about the space?
Things that you felt like you
could use the previous
experience and it just
didn't apply?
Anything that you would
be willing to share?
BETTINA HEIN: Well, so the
commonality between the two
companies is the heavy text
analytics, right?
Text to speech software
is all about that.
But here as well.
I mean, we do a lot of analytics
on the metadata
surrounding all the videos
that we tap into.
And one of the things from a
user perspective that I still
find astounding is that this
concept of, and I'll use air
quotes here, a "viral video"
still exists in the heads of
lots of people.
We'll just create a video and
we'll put it out there.
And it will go viral.
That concept still exists.
Maybe not for the people
watching this webinar.
But out there, people that are
creating content don't really
know a lot about the metadata
optimization
that you have to do.
And also that you have to see
a video as a member of the
social network.
One thing that Andreas didn't
really talk about very much in
the demo are our cross-platform
analytics.
So looking at what videos are
being watched and commented on
via Facebook, on Twitter,
LinkedIn.
And we aggregate all
of that data.
So the really advanced people
in the space, they look at
what a video is doing
in the social space.
They don't rely solely on
putting it up on YouTube and
hoping that people will come.
It's not a build it and
we will come scenario.
So you have to embed it.
You have to work on
link building.
You have to share it out
via different networks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I guess
what folks expect is you just
put together this interesting
content, you put it out there,
and it'll go viral.
And the reality is not
quite like that.
BETTINA HEIN: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you
need to do some--
BETTINA HEIN: Another astounding
thing is that often
times the content that people
think they should be creating
is diametric to what
actually people are
watching in the space.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
BETTINA HEIN: That's why
we developed the radar.
I mean, we've helped very
big companies and brands
completely change the kind of
content that they're creating,
what they're putting in there.
Because they're seeing, oh,
this will get zero views.
There are no people watching
that associated with our brand
or our content.
ANDREAS GOELDI: One great
example is the length, the
duration of the video.
So most people still think that
a YouTube video has to be
a maximum of two minutes long
because people have such a
short attention span and they
will never watch it.
And we can basically prove with
our technology in almost
every industry that that's
absolutely not true.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Not
true anymore.
ANDREAS GOELDI: People watch
more and more long form
content on YouTube, up
to 20 minutes long.
And if you really have
interesting content, if you
have something to say, people
will absolutely watch it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So we still
have a little time left.
Jeremy, we wanted to go
through the Q&A--
JEREMY WALKER: Sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --part.
I know we have a couple of
questions for the moderator.
So should we get to it?
Before we get into that, I
know you looked in the
Analytics API.
Have you looked at the v3
version of the API as well?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Yes,
absolutely.
We have actually started
to experiment with it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Any
additional feedback?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Yes, it's
great, first of all.
I think it's great because it's
very lean and efficient.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
ANDREAS GOELDI: The old
API used to be a bit
heavy in some ways.
I mean, XML and so on.
And now you have this very
lean JSON framework.
And you can really shape it
in a way that it gives you
exactly the data
that you want.
And that's really a great
advantage, I think especially
for mobile developers.
And I'm definitely looking
forward to switching to the
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Have you
tried the Python Client
Library yet?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Yes.
That's another great thing.
I mean, the old library for G
Data was a bit, you know, old
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
we're stuck at
version one of the API.
So old school.
This is all about to change.
ANDREAS GOELDI: Right, yeah.
So it's great.
It's great progress really.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, we have a couple
questions.
I'll start with the ones,
because there's quite a few
for you guys.
So one of our questions is from
Paris, actually. "Most of
the examples I see in this video
are related to business,
to consumer campaigns.
What advice for business to
business service delivery
companies do you have?" Like,
one size fits all?
They just a little more
information on that.
BETTINA HEIN: We actually
recently did a study of the
top 100 brands in the world,
how they are using YouTube.
And among those are actually the
winners of our study, so
to speak, the number of views,
the number of videos that they
publish, are technology
companies.
And often times they
are B2B companies.
And we see some really good
examples, for example, Intel
does really well with YouTube.
Cisco does very well
with YouTube.
And what you can learn from
those companies is actually
that you have to create content
that is interesting
for a broad mass of people.
But then you have to
segment it down.
So Intel, for example, will have
examples that are for a
particular chipset.
And they just have a developer
explaining the new
developments around what
they're doing, how
functionalities work, how this
works when you're integrating
this into the boards that
you're working on.
And that doesn't have
to be totally sexy.
The same goes for lots
of product videos.
People really do a
lot of research.
And most people know that
YouTube's search box is the
second largest search
engine in the world.
So if you have a really
technical product and
something that people usually
would want to see in action,
that's what works for
video very well.
We had a milling company
do videos.
And it was very interesting that
they wanted, for example,
they figured out that they had
to absolutely put no music on
their videos.
Because people wanted
to hear the shavings
fall with the machine.
JEREMY WALKER: That's amazing.
BETTINA HEIN: So it really
depends on your vertical.
And then another key is
to always use the
content that you have.
In email marketing for B2B
that works really well.
Integrate those videos
in there.
You'll get click-throughs.
Use it in trade shows.
Use it in those B2B areas.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, great.
Let's see we got another
one here for you.
So "what advice would you get
for dealing with cultural
differences in positioning
video content?
Do you have any recommendations
that work best
for different parts
of the world?
How's the approach effected?"
BETTINA HEIN: Well, it's
definitely different.
YouTube's dominance is
not as big in some
areas of the world.
So if you have a YouTube only
strategy, in some countries
you may want to think
about that.
For example, I think
in France--
I think this question is from
France-- if you're doing movie
trailers, I think they have
[FRENCH], where people go if
they're looking for movie
trailers instead of YouTube.
But apart from that, I think you
have to be really in tune.
If you're doing a multi-national
strategy, you
have to be in tune with pop
culture and political
developments in that
culture if you're
creating content for that.
So let's say you're
targeting Greece.
A Greek viewer will know
what Golden Dawn is.
Whereas a Chinese viewer might
be very confused if you
mentioned that.
Another thing to be aware of is
that passionate communities
on YouTube are often
very international.
So looking into that if you're
optimizing your metadata, your
tagging, your descriptions,
think about using not just
English, but also some other
languages if you're targeting
those international audiences.
And a third thing is for
content creators, that
aesthetic tastes vary
often culturally.
So for example, in Latin
America stark
lighting is very popular.
And color schemes are very
different than tastes would
be, for example, in
northern Europe.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Great.
That's some great information.
Let's see.
So the other one we have is,
of course, is Google
Developers hiring?
Jarek, you want to
take that one?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Andreas
was looking at me.
I hoped you were going to
take the other one.
Yes.
We are hiring.
Both YouTube Developers and
Developer Relations as well as
Google Developer Operations
is hiring.
To find out more go to
developers.google.com/jobs
where you can see all the job
descriptions and the positions
that we have open.
And as far as the type of work
we do we hang out in the
studio every Wednesday.
But beyond that, and we were
going to mention that, we have
a bunch of speaking
engagements.
Jeremy was just speaking at the
Silicon Valley Code Camp.
That was last week, right?
JEREMY WALKER: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I actually
came back from Mexico, where
we were hosting a Latin America
Google Developers
Group Summit.
So community leaders from a
number of Latin American
countries came together.
We visited Telmex hub in Mexico,
which is just an
incubator, and shared
office space.
So it quite exciting.
And then we have a number of
events actually coming up
where we'll be speaking.
I think DevFest West is coming
up this weekend.
JEREMY WALKER: This
weekend, right.
We'll be speaking there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
And then if anybody's actually
watching from Korea, we're
looking to participate in an
event there mid-November.
So again, if you would like
to join us, please go to
developers.google.com/jobs
and learn more there.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
We actually have a couple
more questions.
BETTINA HEIN: And Pixability
is hiring as well.
So if devs are interested
in YouTube, absolutely.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, we have a couple
more questions
that we'll fly through.
And then we'll close it out.
So "how do captions provided in
English on YouTube videos,
for example in French,
effect SEO?"
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So captions
are definitely something very
important for SEO.
And if you can upload multiple
language versions, that's
definitely helpful.
We typically recommend if you're
really going with a
multilingual strategy, it
typically makes sense to
separate out your channels
by language group.
Simply because then you can
really optimize playlists and
all the metadata around the
channel, even the channel
design for the specific
market.
But uploading captions
is a very good idea.
It really helps.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And then our last one that we
have time for, and this I
think is more general, "how much
of a shake up will things
like Hangouts on air cause in
the brands or in YouTube
channels?"
ANDREAS GOELDI: In the
sense that brands
will use that, or--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I guess, maybe
the question is it's a
different type of video
engagement as an interactive
experience, right?
Rather than video on demand.
Do you see brands
adopting that?
Do you get approached about how
should people use that as
a yet another way to connect
with the customers?
ANDREAS GOELDI: Occasionally
people ask us about how do I
do a live show like
this one here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
ANDREAS GOELDI: So that's
definitely something that
people start discovering
a little bit.
But I think it's still a few
years away at this point.
Because most companies still are
struggling with developing
their video strategy in the
first place just for standard
video content.
So I think it's attractive,
especially if you're going in
the B2B sector and really have
to provide in depth content.
And it's a great format.
And we have been using
it at Pixability very
successfully as well.
So we have a monthly live
webinar, which is actually
airing right now in competition
with this one.
And this has been very
successful for us.
So I think that's definitely
something that
people should look at.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Great.
So maybe--
BETTINA HEIN: Actually the
question came from
[? Cheryl ?]
[? Lock ?]
from Las Vegas, who's
a loyal viewer of
the Pixability webinar.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great
BETTINA HEIN: Hi, Cheryl.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks
for joining.
So maybe I was wrong.
Maybe the next gig is
not ESP, it's live.
So it's audio, video, live
video, and then ESP.
All right, I think this is all
we have time for today.
So thank you very much for
visiting our studio.
Have fun on the West Coast.
And a safe trip back
to Boston.
And Jeremy, as always,
a pleasure.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And I guess
we'll talk to next week,
Wednesday, 10:00 AM
Pacific time.
Bye.
ANDREAS GOELDI: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]